thank you all for joining me today
i'm going to be talking about doing more
with less maximizing
phase appropriate doe strategies and
hopefully by the end of the day
you're not thinking that that means do
the minimal amount
at each phase
so let's go through an overview of what
we're going to talk about
first i'd like to introduce lembek in
case you haven't heard about us yet
then walk through the phases of cmc
development
and how we might maximize the efficiency
at each step
using our doe toolbox what when
why and how and then understand
the analytical variation to set ranges
as part of our pre-doe homework
then i'm going to take a project and
walk it through
early development and late stage
development
and what we would do in doe at each of
those phases
and then talk about a relatively new
auto validation strategy that harnesses
the power
of machine learning for small data sets
to analyze that late stage development
definitive screening design that you can
then use
for de-risking your
testing the model and going and
advancing your
process development
so who are lend back
we are a global pharmaceutical company
specialized in discovering and
developing
innovative treatments for brain diseases
we
our goal is to be number one in brain
health
and if you are interested in learning
more about us or applying for any of our
open mini open positions
please read more about us at
www.lendec.com
we have over 5 000 employees in over 50
countries
our largest stakeholder is the lundbeck
foundation
which allows us to focus on the brain
diseases
that we want to help cure our 2020
revenue
was over 17 billion danish kroner
we treat more than 7 million people per
day with our products
lembeck was founded in 1915 by hans
lundberg
and in 2009 we established a u.s
presence in 2019
munbeck acquired abide pharmaceuticals a
small molecule com
research company in la jolla and alder
biopharmaceutical
in the seattle area that was working on
antibodies
and that's alder was where i was working
our focus is transformative medicines
for niche and rare diseases
and we have run the gamut from early
research for drug discovery
through drug development product
development and supply
we have corporate support and that's
supporting our global presence having
all of the functions for the drug
development process
means that we have an opportunity to
interact with stakeholders
every step along the way which i think
is important as you
as we strive to meet patients needs
let's now talk about the phases of cmc's
development
so after your research and development
group
have defined a product that might meet a
patient's needs
then it gets transferred to the
chemistry manufacturing and control
section
and as we start along this pathway
toward launch
to get the patient get the drugs that
they need
it's going to increase your resources
your personnel and your cost at each
step of the phase
so treating the patients is the goal how
can we balance
the effort and resources to maximize the
speed and efficiency of drug development
as we walk along that development
timeline
when we're in the first step with our
first little diamond here we're working
on
developing the first in human process
this does not need to be the final
process
at this stage but we want to still have
a process that is safe
and epic safe and for the patient
and we can look at how efficacious it is
in this case for the upstream
development group
we're going to focus on choosing a
robust cell line
so that we can maximize the efficiency
of that timeline to get that product in
the clinic
if we can if we don't have to do a cell
line change
that makes life easier for our quality
folk our regulatory folk later on in the
process as the cell line change is a
major
change and we would want to to do extra
work to make sure that that change
is still safe for the patient when
we have that first product going through
phase one clinical trials that's when we
want to initiate our commercial process
development
here we want to optimize for yield and
product
quality because we want to develop the
process that's going to be used for
phase 3 clinical studies
the process that's used for phase three
clinical studies should be the same
process
used for commercial launch typically
after we've developed that process is
when
many companies start the process
characterization in order to have
greater understanding of the operating
space greater understanding of your
of your process that's when a lot of
time and effort is spent
on running experiments to establish
that understanding for safety again for
the patient
with the goal to meet a validated
commercial process that can then be
launched
i'm hoping to show you today there are
steps that we can do
in step two that may make
the step three more efficient
and that you can leverage for a quicker
time frame
and one of the ways that we're going to
do that is use our doe
toolbox so what is
design of experiment and why would we
want to do it instead of using
one factor at a time or o fat studies
design experiments are experimental
strategies that are mathematically
designed to extract the maximum
information from the least number of
runs
when do we use them but there are
different type of doe strategies
so i would i truly think of doe as a
toolbox
when we're early in development i'm
going to use screening designs
in this case i'm focusing on the factor
that i'm changing
or think of it as a knob that you're
turning
what which of those knobs are the most
important for your process
and so that's in our case we're looking
at tighter or yield
and product quality when we get
to the later stage when we have
developed our commercial process
that's when we really want to focus on
characterization
and we want to predict an outcome
depending on what that factor or
parameter setting
is within that design space and
this is understanding for late stage
development and even
post launch why would we want to do
this we want to gain understanding of
parameter
interactions for instance if you're
baking cookies you could probably
understand that there is
a interaction between the time that you
place the cookies in the oven
and the temperature if you have the
temperature too high
you might be too crispy on the outside
and gooey on the inside
and likewise if it's too low you might
have to increase your time
so having an understanding of those
those parameter interactions how would
that affect
us we might if you tried to maximize or
optimize a strategy one factor at a time
you would be optimizing safe for ph you
would find that perfect ph while keeping
all
other factors constant but then when you
try to optimize for temperature what if
you were at the
wrong ph for that temperature
to meet your highest yield if we could
do that at the same time
you'll maximize your speed of efficiency
to develop that process
so we want to gain that understanding
and also
do it in a time efficient process
our little schematic in the bottom right
just shows
each dot shows how many runs are going
to
be needed and in this case this is just
a
three dimensional space or two
two or three factors but can you imagine
how many factors that are
affecting your process can be much
higher
now let's talk about how you would do a
design of experiment
first collaborate with your stakeholders
remember to keep the patient in mind if
the research
folk can talk to the cmc manufacturing
and find out what is needed
to speed process through development
in one case we had a antibody coming out
of research
that was sticking to all of the tubing
that
was used for the product quality for in
analysis we quickly determined that that
was not a very manufacturable antibody
and switched to the number two in line
and that has gone forward
and been launched into a product let's
determine the timeline
and resources available that's going to
help you determine what type of doe
strategy you're going to use identify
your parameters to investigate so have
an
understanding of the reproducibility and
the standard deviation
for your process it can be for a prior
project
but you need to have that understanding
before you set those ranges
when you do set those ranges be brave
go wide to ensure higher signal than
noise ratio
you don't have to try to hit
your best conditions in the experimental
design
you're hoping that the mathematical
models will be able to predict
what is your best condition at the end
of the study
so pick the model that fits your goal
are you going to do a screening design
or are you going to do a
characterization design characterization
designs are usually done with fewer
parameters but there's more runs so that
you have really
understanding of the operating space
many software are available now that can
harness the
computing power for modern designs i
use jump full disclosure i am on the
jump steering committee
that is the program that has worked well
for me and
i like many of the designs that are
coming out from the developers that work
there
now we're ready to execute your
experiment complete your experiment
in random order that is very
important if you need to talk to the
operators on the floor
if there is a particular parameter
that is difficult to change you want to
include that in your design
so that you can block by that parameter
now we're ready to do the fun part the
analysis
in for definitive screening design
brad jones has created the fit
definitive screening
platform and that it is available in
regular jump
what i'm going to talk to you today
about as well is a new strategy
developed by chris gothwalt and phil
ramsey
which is an auto validation strategy
that's using
machine learning for small data sets
that for this particular strategy will
require
jump pro the benefit of using the auto
validation strategy
is it de-risks that final step
of doe which is to test your model
remember george box all models are wrong
but some are useful in our industry
every run and is is expensive
can be expensive and so you want to
speed up and make sure that the time
that you're taking
to test your model is the most practical
and
has the highest chance of success and
using the auto validation strategy
has worked well in my case
now we're ready for our pre-doe homer
so this is one project
that we
[Music]
finished and i've used this project
to have some understanding of the
equipment that i'm using
the graph on the far left
the tighter graph is showing a tighter
profile over time
the x-axis is showing the culture time
in days
and the y-axis is showing the bio-ht
normalized idg titer and again thank you
to roche custom biotech for the
invitation to speak today the bio ht is
one of my favorite pieces of equipment
and we are very happy with its
reproducibility and consistency
but in this case we're also measuring
what's the consistency between different
bench scales
for bioreactors we have the 250 mil
amber we have a 3 liter and 14 liter
single use vessel and we're seeing nice
reproducibility between scales
between users and between rent sets
on the right side i have a product
quality
from a analytical reference standard
that's been
in the in the middle graph is overlays
of
a capillary isolect focusing
graph the peaks
that are two the far right and far left
peak are markers
the peaks that are to the left of the
tallest
peak are considered acidic species and
these can
this is a product quality parameter that
we investigate especially early in
development
it's a measurement of how your protein
can
can change over time and it's especially
impacted by ph time and temperature
so for this reference standard i want
to know before i get into a designed
experiment what is the variation in the
analytics analytics
what's the inter if there's if it's run
between different instruments
between different reference slots
between different analyzers
on the far right graph i have the shaded
area that is showing the range that
we're seeing
for acidic species this has been
the mean is normalized at one i need to
go back to my analytics group
and just double check and say is there
something special about the outliers
that are
that are flying to the bottom of that
mean or is this true deviation that were
that i could be seeing in my
experimental design
then i want to make sure that my ranges
are wide enough
that my signals to noise is going to be
higher and i can make informed decisions
going forward in my modeling
now let's talk about setting factor
ranges
i've been doing design experiments for a
long time
and i have a lot of i've been had a lot
of
requests for doing multiple levels of an
experiment
and for this project i'm showing
to the far left the full data set where
we've tested
multiple ph conditions
so in this case it's just one factor
multiple
levels in the end we found the
optimize setting which is in blue
but let's take this as an example for
how we should set ranges
during a doe the next graph over
to the right is using a conservative
range setting
in this case the middle point points
that were tested were the platform
process conditions and it looks if we
were using that conservative range
setting
that the platform conditions were the
best conditions
to go forward with and in fact
if we went up in ph
we might be getting into a dangerous
spot but
it looks pretty safe for where we're at
but you'll notice that we didn't quite
hit
the optimized setting if we had used a
wider range
then we are able to predict
mathematically
the optimized condition that turned out
to be the optimized condition and
we also note that if we drop in ph we're
starting to see a significant drop off
in our tighter yield
we get that same information with a bold
range setting and what's
uh and again this is just three levels
we're still able to see and determine
mathematically what the optimized
ph settings should be for this process
so i encourage you you could do not need
to test
every level in between
for a parameter that you're setting and
this is one of the powers
of goes
now let's get into our case study we
know that our equipment's working we
know
what the settings that we need to do and
we're going to be bold
in our range setting
for this project we start with early
stage development
so we're taking the from our cell line
development group
they're screening the top 12 to 48 cell
lines in shake flasks
and they identify the top 4 to eight
cell lines to go forward
for bioreactor screening in this case
our filters to decide if a cell line is
going to go forward for processing
our yield product quality and
manufacturability
and then another key point
to look at is stability if this cell
line is passage for multiple generations
does it still maintain its genetic
stability
is the product once it's put into your
final gone through the purification and
it's in its final formulation buffer
is it stable over time at the
temperature that you want it
to be the stability aspect of
the filter is going to by necessity take
time but for manufacturability we can be
poking at that a little bit earlier
again if we don't have to do
a cell line change after phase one
we can save time and resources in in the
company
for not doing a major change
so we're going to talk about more about
manufacturability
so let's explore manufacturability with
the top
in this case three cell lines i usually
take the top two or three cell lines
we want to balance the desirability of
the response with the robustness
across a moderate process range so in
this case i'm not
being very bold with the ph range
settings
that we're doing if you look at cell
line a
it had the highest titer from the from
the previous
uh slide when it was run under the
platform process but it has the lowest
manufacturability what do i mean by that
when you do minor changes in ph we see a
significant
drop-off in titer cell line b
had the lowest titer but it was fairly
robust across the same
moderate ph range cell line c
had a little bit of movement with our ph
range that we were testing
and high tider so that's the cell line
that we're going to proceed
forward with for development
and again this is early stage
development we don't need to have the
final
process here we just need to know which
cell line
is the best one that we want to continue
forward
while the product is is going through
the phase one
clinical trials
so while that's in phase one clinical
trials we're taking this project through
late stage development
so let's talk about case study number
two
so let's perform a risk assessment
before we start
doing the upstream late stage
development
and we want to avoid prior assumptions
this is a new cell line
it's a new antibody let's bring all of
the parameters
to play that could be affecting the
responses that we care about
in this case the definitive screening
design is chosen for optimization
because we don't there's many parameters
or factors that could be affecting the
responses
that we care about the definitive
screening design
is chosen because it's a very efficient
use of resources for investigating
four or more parameters not only
that it investigates the low middle
and high setting for continuous factors
this allows fitting of a curve or having
your quadratic model terms
you can include two level categorical
factors
for instance if we had two different
media types that we wanted
to include it's
um also you can do blocking effects
for instance if you don't have enough
reactors to run all in one set
you can block by run sets if there are
resources
are available and you have the time you
can add
runs by a factor of four to increase
your power
these are uh the definitive screening
design
was discovered by brad jones
and chris noxzeim and so i have some
references here
i also have reference to the jump user
community
with a blog from brad jones on the
proper and improper use of definitive
screening designs
this blog i go to regularly
for help in describing to other people
the power of definitive screening
designs
so we met with all of our teams we
decided what the top
10 factors are that we're going to use
in this case we needed blocking
because we needed to run it over 4 run
sets
so we checked the n minus 1 seed density
the production tank c density starting
temperature
the ph setting the temperature shift
the day of the temperature shift the
glucose target level
the feed a and the feed b concentration
and the timing of the feed start
with all of these 10 factors we can
investigate this in a mere 24 runs
with and each of the factors that we are
testing
it is the results are not biased
or confounded by
each other two-factor interaction
what does that mean the seed density is
not
we're going to be able to understand the
importance of the seed density on this
process
by itself and it's not going to be
influenced if there happens to be
an interaction between ph and
temperature
so this is a very powerful aspect of
this design
and that is shown by the color color
relation map that you see in the middle
there
so here are our results in blue
we see the definitive screening design
results of those 24 runs that we just
described
in red is the platform process in the
top left graph
we're looking again at the bio ht
igg titer over time
and you can see that we're seeing
from this is the normalized titer so
we're seeing
very low titers all the way to the
up to 100 we didn't find a condition in
the doe
that is much higher than the platform
process conditions
again that's okay that's not the purpose
of the dsd
we're hoping that we'll be able to model
conditions
that we haven't tested yet that are
going to increase our titer
for growth we're also seeing some
conditions that
severely limit growth some conditions
that we do have
higher growth that's not necessarily a
good thing
but we now know from this range of
responses
that i'm definitely going to be able to
find factors that are very important to
yield
and important to grow the right
two graphs on this slide are
product quality so on day 14 we
take a sample we
purify it through the first purification
step
protein a capture and then we sent it
off
off to analytics for analysis the top
right
graph is the results from size exclusion
chromatography
and we're looking at aggregates if
there's a lot of aggregates
in your process that could potentially
be
a product quality risk for your patients
in this case i'm plotting against the
platform process results
and you'll notice that the range that
we're seeing for the platform process
is very similar to the range that we're
observing
with the doe now that doesn't mean that
the doe can't predict
because we did have great predictions
for
size exclusion aggregate values
but what it does tell us is that four
size exclusion aggregates
this process and cell line are fairly
robust
we're not seeing a lot of wiggle for
the charge species from the cief acidic
assay that we're looking at the red
platform process results range from
about 0.5 to 0.6 of
the normalized acidic peak but for the
doe
we're seeing from 0.2 to 0.9
we're seeing a very wide range so i
definitely have some
factors that we tested that are
impacting that acidic speed
and we're definitely outside the
variation
range that we saw with acidic peak
so i can be sure that my signal to noise
is quite high
so now we have our results let's
go and analyze them in this case
i'm using jump this is everyone has this
available
in regular jump and using the fit
definitive screen platform that brad
jones created
and how does this analysis work it's
it's a three
stage process in the first stage
it looks at the main effects or your the
top 10 parameters and it says for
for all of those top 10 parameters how
much
do each of those parameters changing
affect the response
of titer in this in the second
stage we take the residuals or the
remaining
information that is not explained by
those top 10 factors
changing and it says okay how are the
interactions
working or how are the the quadratic
terms
is there curvature within any of these
parameters that we're seeing
and then the final stage is it glues
those stage one
and stage two together to come up with
your mathematical model
to describe this response
i'm showing in this option one we'll
notice that the quadratic terms
obey strong heredity and the
interactions obey strong heredity
thus those boxes are both checked
what does that mean that means if the
main effect
is not chosen or the main parameter by
itself
did not have a strong response on
the titer then it would not be clue
included
as a in a curvature term
or in an interaction with any other
factor
and so this is a very simple model and
you have less chance
of overfitting your model the
bottom right graph is a pareto plot and
that
shows us the importance it's a way to
show the importance of each
model term in which is
think back to your algebra it's just one
part of that equation
so in this case starting ph is highly
important
the next term model term that it found
most important
was a curvature between
in the temperature shift and then it
found
curvature in ph being
similarly important to the temperature
shift
then temperature shift as a main effect
and then
it found a very slight interaction
between
the starting ph and the temperature
shift and in this case
the block was important so that means
there's something
that i am not aware of that was changing
between block and block
maybe box run set to run set maybe the
media lots
there was slight variations so there's
something that i could do
to tighten up my reproducibility between
blocks
let's go to option two
again i take george box to heart all
models are wrong
some are useful so i like to look at
multiple models
and get a feel for my data in this case
we're going to say
the quadratic terms don't have to obey
strong heredity
so in other words there might be a case
where there's curvature
for a parameter that is more important
than that parameter by itself so if we
look at the results here
starting ph is still the top factor
and it's in the pareto plot followed by
temperature shift so this model is still
picking out the same top two factors
but now we're starting to see that the
production seed density
has some curvature to it as we might
expect
also there's some curvature that has
been found with the feed b
percentage so in this case we
have a few more model terms that have
been included
let's continue on to option three
in this case we're going to go back and
say that the quadratic terms
obey strong heredity but the
interactions
do not so in this case there might be an
interaction
or they're actually is being pulled out
an interaction
between the starting ph and the feed
b percentage also
we're bringing in the nutrient feed
start time in
hours and feed 8
with some interactions there feed a
appears to perhaps have an interaction
with the temperature shift
etc our top
factor again is the curvature term for
ph
and then ph is the second term most
important term for this model
so each model is still finding ph as
being the most important
model parameter that we tested that is
affecting titer
option four this is my favorite you're
not supposed to have
favorite this is my favorite i like to
have
all possible combinations so i don't
have any restrictions
on the quadratic terms or the
interaction
terms in this case
we have feed a we have the n minus 1
seed density
and there's some curvature there we have
some interactions that are coming on
but the starting ph is still the most
important
parameter so we is there another model
we can use
yes in regular jump there is also
a method where we can use the stepwise
forward method using the minimum
aic corrected i also
like to look at this model and i'm
showing what i'm depicting here in these
graphs or how you would do that
so if you take your 10 factors and
you add them to your model terms as a
response
service so that means that you take all
your 10 factors
every possible interaction between those
10 factors
and all of the quadratic terms for each
of those 10 factors that's what the
response surface model is
and then i add to the y the response
that i'm looking for
in this case it's the normalized igg
tighter
and then you hit the
you start going forward with the minimum
aic
aicc i am not a statistician so if you
need more information on that i would
point you to the jump user community to
have an understanding of how this model
works
in this case we are now finding the
glucose target
as a that has some curvature that may be
affecting
our are tighter but again the starting
ph setting and the temperature shift are
the two model terms that are that are at
the top of our list
so another way to look at this is in a
color map
so all of the five models that we have
looked at
chose ph and temperature shift as being
the most important factors out of the 10
tested
the simplest model the option one
with heredity enforced
for interactions and quadratic terms
only found ph and temperature shift
the other models found varying
combinations
what is the best model to use and again
you want to make sure what you're
testing
to go forward with or your decisions to
go forward with that
your model is going to predict that so
how can we
de-risk that next step or that decision
to go forward
one way is to use a new method developed
by chris gotwalt
and phil ramsey using auto validation
for small data sets
so using auto validation method for
small data sets
machine learning methods have
revolutionized the analysis of big
data sets you can use a fraction of the
data for training or building the model
let's say we use 70 of that data for
training
then you use 20 of that data for
validating that
model and then 10 for testing the model
that can all be done in silico that's
not
that method is not easily applied to
designed experiments
each run in the experiment is carefully
configured mathematically
to so that you get the maximum amount of
information
i'm going to refer you to gr chris
gottwalt who is a jump developer and
phil ramsey
they gave a talk in 2018 you can
follow the link here to see the full
talk i'm going to walk you very briefly
through
what they came up with and what i have
used successfully
and i'm going to show you here for this
project
so the setup for the analysis you're
going to create
a copy of the original doe data set and
add a validation
column so the original data set is going
to be your
training set the copy is going to be
used
you're used for your validation you're
going to create a new
formula column for the fractionally
weighted both
bootstrap method and that is the formula
that i'm showing
to the right then you're going to create
a new column for the null factor
in this case the null factor is just a
randomly
derivative result that's independent of
the monitored response such as titer
there is a wonderful add-in if you have
jump pro
that i will refer you to that does all
of this
automatically and so you can find that
in the link shown
what does this look like
the top the original data set is shown
in orange
as the training tip we just make a copy
of that we have that for the validation
when you're using jump pro you would put
your
y response in this case tighter is what
we're looking for
in the y you would put the paired
fractionally weight bootstrap in the
frequency
the validation column in the validation
and then you would do a full response
surface
as we did for the stepwise in this case
you're going to add that null factor
that's just
a random random
generated column random number
that random number is going to that
random number is going to change
for each time you run a simulation
because now we're going to use the
machine learning in this case i like to
use lasso or double lasso
for small data sets and i'm going to
perform
2500 simulations in each simulation the
null factor
is set to new set of random numbers
and in order to do that you have that
i'm showing this
how you would set up that simulation in
jump pro
after it completes that 2500 simulations
which takes a little bit of time
then you can identify the percentage of
time
that the null strain was randomly
included to be important as a factor
we know that the null strain is the null
factor is not important it's just random
noise
because we generated it to be that way
so in this case
every model term that is included
less times than the null factor which is
random noise
we know that that is not important and
those are shown in gray
the null factor response is shown in red
to the far left we see that ph setting
and temperature shift
are have been included in more than
double the amount of
models of those 2 500 simulations
than the null factor that matches what
we knew already
that ph and temp shift are highly
important but now we have some blue
factors
that are they've been included slightly
more times
than the random noise of this of the
null factor
so if we add that to our model and we
look and see
what what the results are
the starting temperature has been found
as being blue feed start time and n
minus one
seed density are three additional
factors to ph
and temperature shift that might also be
important
i will tell you that with follow-up
experimentation
starting temperature was found to be
important and only
option two that we had looked at before
found starting temperature as being
being very important still
now let's test the model once we've
de-risked the
final conditions that we need to do
let's
do that perform that test in the wet lab
we use this auto validation method for
each of the factors that we had
each response of interest to us so
growth viability
yield all of our product quality
parameters
each response receives its own
individual model and
you can save that prediction formula to
the data table
to the right i'm showing the predicted
values for the optimized model
the upper green band and the lower red
band
are showing the upper and lower 95
confidence interval
the blue bar is showing the actual
prediction
and the two black dots are the duplicate
uh
wet lab results that we used to test the
model
so we had a model that worked and
we increased our overall yield by over
20
from the original uh
platform process conditions in addition
we have
a lot more information about the product
quality parameters
that matter going forward
so in summary prior to starting doe have
some
understanding of your process
variability all along the path
understand how bench equipment is
skilled to manufacturing for past
products
be bold in setting your process ranges
increase your signal to noise ratios to
create more useful
models maximize your efficiency of the
cmc development through the phase
appropriate doe strategies
this requires iterative communication
with your cross-functional stakeholders
balance your resources in a
phase-appropriate manner thoughtful
designed
experiments can increase your overall
speed of development
focus on the manufacturability in early
stage don't try to find the best process
then you can identify and minimize
possible future roadblocks
such as a cell line change large dsd
doe studies in late stage development
can be leveraged
for increased efficiency of process
characterization studies needed to
establish a commercial process
using the auto validation with
fractionally weighted bootstrapping
provides useful prediction models from
screening designs such as the definitive
screening design
i have lots of acknowledgments for the
team that was responsible for creating
this work our upstream development
team that had been led by mike's lama
are downstream led by jeff lee and ethan
oila
our analytical team uh led by pay
key and mary jo phoenix and especially
our scientific computing with kira and
pat
being able to access your data very
quickly
and look at it across groups that has
been
fabulous thank you and do you have any
questions